why does it stay
minister the importance of this leech service
she has been warned time and again of the consequences by
patients by houseboats
international research
what I just mentioned by the inspection
why does it stay
minister to the importance of these grajesdien
only in the Netherlands
and in the peaceable kingdom
dermatoliberal legislation has been implemented
that private equity
gets all the space
why does this minister continue to pass motions
of the room
I brought 1 number
one of Mr.
bushoff and Mrs.
van de Berg
12-9-2023 adopted
one of uh
Mrs. Marijn is uh
Mrs.
bigger in general political considerations
21 September 2023
actually practically nothing done with it
and emotion of myself too
adopted by majority
January 25 for private action from the
very careful to resist chairman
it did not happen
why does this minister continue to watch our concern
from within is eaten empty by these parasites
and why has this minister
50,000 co-workers with patients in uncertainty started